[Musik]
ich das nur unsere Fußball
wenn er WM in der wirst die stattfindet
in einer schweren Land mit
menschenrechtsproblem und im Wald wie
höchste co2-
sie 2002 ist klar das ist schützt
fußball-realität der Tod 22
[Musik]
so denen froh gehören mir in der letzten
Minute intensiv recherchiert mehr das
sind der Yasin fußball-liebhaber und
Moderator bei RTS ich Jenny Journalistin
und Moderatorin
[Musik]
reihenform eigentlich total
unkommerzieller
aber das heißt
in diesem Land wird werden die Frauen
quasi misshandelt
natürlich anschauen ich finde es nicht
okay aber
relativ skeptisch und kritisch was die
Wehen kommen
[Applaus]
wir holt sich revierten Stadt ohne
Fußballtradition erwähnt das war mein
vier Schritte Schritt 1 lautet relevant
werden in der Sportwelt
[Musik]
Offensive balanciert angefangen mit dem
Tennisturnier in Doha 1993
es gibt Weltmeisterschaft im Handball
Rad Turnen oder die lichterathletik
insgesamt findet in Katar zäh
verschiedene
an der Universität forscht Laura rovitz
zu Golfregion ganz besonders zu Katha
Sport bietet die Gelegenheit für Katha
sich ein sehr positives und
fortschrittliches modernes Image zu
geben oder es spielt in Katas nationaler
Erzählungen sehr gut rein so einen
eigenen Entwicklungsweg zu gehen sehr
stark Visionen zu haben
eine gewissen Fortschritt zu folgen und
da bietet Sport die Möglichkeit genau
diese Erzählung zu stärken und nach
außen zu verkaufen aber ich sind
irgendwie absurd das werden wir so
probiert aus dem nicht eigentlich
identitätserschaffen wo eigentlich nicht
mit der eigenen Geschichte hat also es
ist nicht so dass Katha keine eigenen
sportradition hätte es gibt verschiedene
aus der Tradition entlehnte Sportarten
es gibt die Falknerei es gibt
Segeln reiten auf Kamelien auf Pferden
aber das sind eben alles Sachen die zwar
so voll touristisch neu belebt wurden
aber Fußball gehört definitiv nicht dazu
[Musik]
groß wie Schweiz
ich quatscht zwischen zwei Grossmacht
Saudi-Arabien und Iran vor ihnen wird
Katar immer wieder unter Druck setzt
adrum ist internationale Aufmerksamkeit
für katharis wichtig ist
sind aber nur die wenigsten Kataris fast
90% sind Arbeitsmigranten also
Bauarbeiter
ihre recht sind
das gleiche gilt auch für Frauen sie
sind Öffentlichkeit drum fast unsichtbar
die wichtigste innahmequelle vom Land
Erdöl und vor allem Erdgas sie macht
tälfte vom Bruttoinlandprodukt aus
und genau da rund 2 Motiv für die
katarische sportoffensive Spiel
Katha ist dafür bekannt dass sie
enorme Erdgas Ressourcen haben aber
diese Ressourcen sind endlich und da
kommt jetzt eben die Frage nach einer
Diversifizierung der Wirtschaft nach
einer Neuausrichtung der Wirtschaft auf
und Katha versuchte eigentlich wie auch
viele andere Staaten in der Region
stärker in Tourismus in das
Transportwesen in Bausektor und so
weiter zu investieren okay also es geht
einfach im Endeffekt doch auch ums
geschafft und ums Geld
identitätsverbinder ja definitiv also
ich glaube das Fußball auch ein Geschäft
ist dass ich bei Fußball Politik und
Geschäft vermischen das können wir auch
in Europa beobachten dazu brauchen wir
eigentlich gar nicht so weit gucken dass
es was man schon lange sehen kann und
bei Katha ist es ist eben so dass mein
Kater jetzt versucht als
Wirtschaftsstandort attraktiv zu machen
man möchte internationale Investoren
anziehen man Konk mit den anderen
kleinen Golfstaaten um internationale
Märkte und in dieser Rivalität ist es
eben wichtig sich eine eigene Identität
ein eigenes Image aufzubauen
können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Schritt 2 auf dem Weg zur WM man
brauchte kooperative Partner
FIFA and gemeinnütziger Verein gründeten
1904 fassbar weniger europäische Länder
schon bald sie erlaubt lang funktioniert
FIFA
[Musik]
zum Achter Waldverband wird FIFA erst ab
der 70er Jahre der Fußball wird bald
wieder
reißt aus Fußball Entwicklungshelfer in
verschiedene
aus der kleinen
[Musik]
statt viel aus gut 200 Mitgliedsverband
hufteilt die sechs Kontinentalverband
hier stelle dir noch Größe
unterschiedlich viel Mitglieder im
sogenannte fifa-fluss
bis 2016 hat das Gremium noch FIFA
Exekutivkomitee
24 Männer wo die wichtigsten
Entscheidungen
als Präsident prägt hat
wir machen das
Idee Kanton wo ja die letzten beiden
mit dem RTS Journalisten
Dokumentarfilm produziert
wir fahren bis zehn
[Musik]
oder was
direkt im Bahnhof auf der anderen Seite
vor der Rhone Maschine
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
im Archiv findet Bilder von damals vom
Sepp blatterturnier in Ulrichen
es zeigt wie ein Blatt dass sie Fußball
Kosmos funktioniert
das Sepp um gar vor der nationaler und
internationale fußballprominanz
teils
wenn man die gewisse Popularität
und
dass wir denen
[Musik]
Fußballwelt mit ihm als König
2015 hat das letzte Turnier
stattgefunden vom Glamour früherer
besonders
[Musik]
der Platz ist jetzt oder Spitze vom
mächtigsten Sportverband von der Welt
als Arbeiterkind katholisch
aufgewachsene einfachsten Verhältnis
[Musik]
er
als Fussballer schafft es immerhin in
die erste Liga Karriere macht er aber
vor allem abseits vom Rasen er studiert
Wirtschaft und Politik wird
oberstimmilitär und stiegen ist
Sportbusiness i
[Musik]
würde sagen meine Verlobte oder meine
Lebens also Verlobte ist die FIFA
[Musik]
zurück in unseren
FIFA so richtig ist
Skandal 2010
isl erfährt mit Sitz im Zug sie hat wird
FIFA jahrelang fernsehrecht verkauft
[Musik]
Millionen anschmiergelder kassiert haben
oft deckt wird das Ganze im Jahr 2010
also kurz vor der WM vergrub nach Katar
und mit drin zwei Mitglieder von FIFA
Exekutivkomitee
und der Ricardo degera aus Brasilien
unter Platte da hätte vor gewusst
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der britische Journalist ein
Vorwurf konfrontiert
[Musik]
Videos
seniorios digital
[Musik]
sie und noch
like Michael
hallo möchtest
das ist Prime
Mama
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unbedingt will auf der anderen Seite
eigentlich der Perfect Match oder
Challenge ja stimmt und das sind sogar
nur 22 nicht 24
jetzt kommt also der dritte und
entscheidende
[Musik]
Kandidatur zu Überzüge und das um jede
Brief
Welt
im Oktober 2010 nur wenige Wochen vor
der WM-Vergabe
[Musik]
Akademie
adamous Nigeria will dafür Fußballplatz
ins im Heimatland
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die beide Bad players werde gesperrt und
so schrumpft mächtige Exekutivkomitee
kurz vor der WM für Coop auf 22
Mitgliedern
es geht 5 Kandidaten
Südkorea Australien und Japan klare
Favorit USA
im vierten Wahlgang blieben nur USA und
Katar übrig
und denn
the winner du organizer
World Cup ist Katar Kater das ist
natürlich eine riesen Überraschung
mit 14 zu 8 Stimmen was da nun jemand
ahnt offenbar sind Bestechungsgelder im
Spiel gesehen und zwar bitte drei
Stimmen vom Ricardo degera im Nicolas
Leos und im
julioz vom isl-skandal obwohl der
Blatter gewusst hat dass sie korrupt
sind ans Dörfer abstimmen
[Musik]
für zwei hat das Sky Konsequenzen
Kommission lebenslang für alle
fußballaktivitäten
und anderen gestützt auf der USA vom
konzilg FIFA Ethikkommission erklärte
mit
Korruption also aus glaubwürdig
[Musik]
sind entscheidend
Wert abstimmig 11 zu elf ausgangen
werden stichenteit beim FIFA Präsident
XI also beim seppler und er seid er
unterstützt
[Musik]
was seit FIFA dazu
unsere recherchengruppe und hätte
probiert vom Gianni Infantino persönlich
er Antwort auf die fruchtskrise
geschickt mit der mit mehr Ultimaten
und was ist passiert noch vier Monate
ist
im Prinzip zwei Sätze
bestimmt aus nicht es ist aus ganz
falsch
das ist falsch das ist explizit drin da
haben sie ja geredet vom Urteil vom FIFA
ethik-komitee aus dem Jahr 2019
[Musik]
FIFA Antwort ist also falsch und auch in
einem anderen Punkt ist stellignal nicht
korrekt
IV schreibt
Garcia Report und da hält die eigentlich
zeigt dass keine Bestechung passiert ist
zum Garcia Report muss man sagen
2014 fertig sind also nicht 2017 wie sie
da sachlich suggerieren
publiziert rund um das
Ziel erreicht es geht los mit dem
Stadionbau was mich heute aber auch weiß
nicht nur Katar hat damals Offenbarung
zum Beispiel Australien
s sie ist Whistleblowing US Australien
und ich ursprünglich einmal teilt sich
vom Bewerbungskomitee
das heißt whatever it takes und den Damm
beschrieb sie eigentlich Schritt für
Schritt wie er aber Australien zu kaufen
hallo hallo
investing about fifty million in
government funding to by the World Cup
what do you think why the restaurant
komplette fact in this beautifact and
the payment with lesson tree moms before
the world for the beat and say you have
to worse Quest we do that
money exactly was given to home in the
process of
Australia try to buy the World Cup aus
Partys one with the half family Dollars
the inted jack wonders Personal
is too I shearner for
Ranger programs
assision in itself a good objective
[Musik]
ja das ist spannend gesehen
mit Kata
und und und
stelle es damals als er bis wahnsinnig
speziell jetzt sind dann Einzelfall und
bei nicht einmal
das Problem das bestimmt
und ich sogar dankbar dafür dass jetzt
eben endlich Aufmerksamkeit
nach Korruptionsvorwürfen auf eine
erneute Wiederwahl auf denen Papier sind
die 24 Männer vom damaligen
Exekutivkomitee
70 Millionen us-dollarstufe
[Musik]
von der 24 funktioniert sie mittlerweile
18 entweder der Korruption überführt
oder wegen dubiose geschafft gesperrt
[Musik]
ab sie ist korruptionsexpertin aus
Deutschland und ich möchte vor ihrer
Wüste weil ich strukturelle
Voraussetzungen
das Korruption der begünstigt worden ist
und auch ob sich mittlerweile
auch auf 12 Minuten drei Stellen hallo
wir regelkonform und ethisch korrekt
sich unternommen und Organisationen
verhalten
von Nizza messiales hat gesagt es gab
damals 2010 keine Alternative zur
Korruption
ist das heute anders
das kann ich jetzt nicht hundert Prozent
sagen aber es sind seitdem ja eine ganze
Menge Veränderungen eingeführt worden es
entscheidet nicht mehr das
Exekutivkomitee das gibt es gar nicht
mehr das heißt jetzt Council bei der
FIFA sondern ist entscheidet der
Kongress das heißt es entscheidet eine
viel größere Personengruppe da wird es
dann schon schwieriger wie man die
beeinflussen kann durch was auch immer
und zum anderen sind ganz andere
complianceanforderungen inzwischen
aufgestellt also insofern ist es
zumindest sehr sehr erschwert worden
100% kann man nirgends auch nicht beim
SRF übrigens Korruption irgendwo
ausschließen wenn wir aber zurückgehen
2010 was hat dann damals Korruption
begünstigt welche Struktur also bei der
FIFA gab es bis zu den beiden
Reformprozessen 2112 und dann nochmal
nach 25 15 2 16
erstens ganz ganz lange Amtszeiten es
war glatter sprach ja auch immer von der
Fußballfamilie man kannte sich man war
miteinander befreundet was ein
Interessenkonflikt ist musste keiner man
half sich untereinander es fehlte auch
an Diversität und vor allen Dingen es
fehlten die Frauen und es fehlte eben
das immer mal neue reinkamen die dumme
Fragen gestellt haben weil dumme Fragen
wirbeln ganz schnell etwas auf und dann
kann man nicht mehr so handeln wie
vorher die Compliance die sie vorhin
bereits angesprochen haben die wurde ja
2014/15 eingeführt das hat sich denn
konkret verändert seither also es hat
sich wie gesagt deutlich was in der
Compliance gewandelt es hat sich aus
meiner Einschätzung manche Journalisten
sehen das anders die Frage der Einzel
Macht des Präsidenten gewandelt also
blatter hat sehr viel mehr Dinge einfach
durchgezogen bei Infantino sehen wir ja
was alles bisher nicht so geklappt hat
zwei Jahresrhythmus für die
Weltmeisterschaft oder anderes der muss
sehr viel mehr ausbalancieren die machte
Verhältnisse haben sich etwas mehr
demokratisiert würde ich sagen der
öffentliche Druck die öffentliche
Beobachtung ist auch noch mal stärker
geworden das hilft der fif was könnte
sich denn noch verändern oder was würden
Sie sich noch wünschen was angepasst
werden würde damit man wieder ich sage
jetzt mal mit einem guten Gefühl Fußball
schauen kann und sich über Korruptionen
keine Sorgen machen muss das Problem ist
sie müssen die ganze Welt ändern mich
hat mal einen Journalist gefragt wann
ist der Fußball und die FIFA sauber habe
ich gesagt wenn die Welt sauber ist wenn
Sie jetzt auf den FIFA-Kongress gehen da
haben sie 2011 nationale Verbände wir
haben ganz viele Länder in der Welt die
mit alltagskorruption mit Korruption im
gesellschaftlichen Leben in der Politik
und so weiter zu tun haben wer wird denn
in einem hochkorrupten Land Präsident
vom Fußball oder vom Schwimmverband oder
vom Leichtathletik verbannt eine Person
die sich in einem korrupten Umfeld
durchsetzen kann es gibt in jedem Land
integrierte Personen gar keine Frage wir
sitzen in vielen Ländern allerdings eher
im Gefängnis als dass sie Präsidenten
eines nationalen Sportverbandes sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
FIFA erhält man reagiert und aufpassen
da mussten die Arbeiter einfach
durcharbeiten
der letzte Schritt auf dem Weg zur WM
ist vielleicht der schwierig an der WM
ist
verunglückt die Arbeiter ökologische
Katastrophe und so weiter jetzt kurz
also darum die Kritik abzuwehren und
sich so gut wie möglich darstellen
damit das klingt lass hier Strategie
unter anderem mittels einer influencer
Agentur
[Musik]
FIFA
19 ist
[Musik]
prominante Botschafter werden
sie natürlich Zeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
be the best World Cup ever
nimmer verteidigt die WM so sehr wie er
sagte
obwohl er selber früher natürlich
Piccolino gesehen
[Musik]
und träumt vom Fussball er studiert use
wird
uefa-generalsekretär und 2016 FIFA
Präsident
[Applaus]
der Piccolino ganz groß
die Projekt im Januar 2022 ziert das
Salder vorüber okay
[Musik]
One Two Three
[Applaus]
schon Oliver Präsident
mit dem FIFA Kanal
das danke
[Musik]
wirbt was nur Gott für die WM
betonspotenzial für die ganze Golfregion
eisversprechend
energieeffiziente Stadion kurze
Transportweg
unvermietbare Missionen kompensiert
werden
[Musik]
CO2-Ausstoß ist komisch ist nur eins von
der 8 Stadien ist wirklich
berücksichtigt
mit der Nachhaltigkeit vor groß
seid er zu der Kalkulation
[Musik]
dankkompensationen zur Klimaneutralität
und das obwohl die Missionen für WM noch
nie so höchst sie sind wie in Katar
3,6 Millionen Tonnen CO2 und das ja
konservativ gerechnet das ist fast so
viel mit Schweizer
[Musik]
jahresortiment eine
der zweite große Kritikpunkt Baustellen
wo ab 2014 erbaut werden es geht um
Sicherheitsmangel Todesfall und
menschenunwürdige Zustand in der
Unterkunft
[Musik]
menschenrechtsorganisationen berichten
vor Zwangsarbeit und ausbütig immerhin
die internationale Kritik hat gewirkt
wenn auch nur langsam
mit FIFA erlaute mannschaftspolizei
auf der Baustelle werden
Schutzvorschriften
Katar reformiert sie Arbeitsrecht und
führt in Mindestlohn für arztmigrante i
als erstes Land in der Region
sogar sogenannte kafala-system wird 2020
offiziell abgeschafft es System in dem
Arbeitnehmer sind
Maßnahmen also um situationsverbesserung
und sich natürlich auch in es besseres
Licht zurück
aber herzlich auf der stadienbaustelle
jetzt wirklich etwas verändert
Schweiz über 40 Jahren
Baustelle inspiziert und wenn man
Bedingungen
ab 2017 ist auch als Teil von einer
internationalen Gruppe mehrmals in
kataxsee das Wetter wenn Sie jetzt die
baustellessend
[Musik]
sie sehen überrascht gesehen was ist
erste Mal auf Kataster sind auf seine
Baustelle
[Musik]
überall Wasserbehälter der denkt dabei
vom Fernseher
will das nun mal schnell anmachen also
das geht nicht da wird man sofort
gesehen dass wenn es nur mal
Schauspieler
verschiedene Kulturen also verschiedene
Kuchen
Stani
je nach Qualifikation und Höhe hat
vierer-zimmer-cout24
regelmäßig gereinigt worden
2017 haben die Inspektionen
das ist
gut möglich
[Musik]
und vor allem auch wir nachhaltig sind
die ganzen
antwortet Ruf Katrin aus See ist
mehrmals in kartaxi als delegiert ich
von der Unia Herze sich in einem
internationalen
angefangen haben sind schon die meisten
Sachen gut
genau ja
40.000
wirklich jetzt aus Arbeitsrecht positiv
aufpasst aber das ist noch nicht überall
implementiert und da wetten wir noch
Rolle spielen also mir Wetter wirklich
dass sie das überall umsetzen das Lied
überall die rechte ja
[Musik]
was fast ja wie verzählt bestätigt auch
MSC international dank internationalem
Druck hat sich sehr viel verändert
besonders auf das stadionbaustelle
Situation Sieg für die grössten Teil von
der gastarbeitenden aber immer noch
schwierig weitere
was passiert nach der WM mit den ganzen
Verbesserungen
[Musik]
wir holen
Fußballtradition erwähnt Kata
[Musik]
sportoffensive
dank korrupt der Fifa-Funktionäre
umstrittene Abstimmung und schließlich
mit Hilfe wenn auch nur teils
erfolgreiche Imagekampagne
[Musik]
spannend oder das Spiel ist so viel
stärker als jegliche Moral und jegliche
[Musik]
nur gut oder nur schlecht und ich finde
es wichtig festhalten oder dass es
einfach uns wahnsinnig schwierig ist und
wir hoffen können
differenziertes Bild zeigen
was meinst du dazu
den Kommentar